do you believe that if you just take
that simple step that you ask your maker
to guide you that he'll guide you yes I
I advise this a lot for people who are
searching put your head on the floor
in the state of frustration like all the
prophets did and ask the creator of the
universe to show you the way to guide
you to the straight path and someone who
sincerely asks for guidance
do you believe that if you just take
that simple step that you ask your maker
to guide you that he'll guide you yes I
I advise this a lot for people who are
searching put your head on the floor in
the state of frustration like all the
prophets did and ask the creator of the
universe to show you the way to guide
you to the straight path and it's
someone who sincerely asks for guidance
[Music]